Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my video about the deleted Nova
storyline from Avengers infinity war an
Avengers endgame the Russo's were
trolling us a little while ago when they
were talking about Nova being in that
big final battle in Avengers endgame but
turns out for a little boy he was
actually going to be in that movie so
we'll break it down and break down
what's going on with the Nova movie that
Marvel is working on right now because
for all you people that have been asking
for Richard Reiter they are working on a
Nova movie we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best Nova
theory on the video so if you don't
remember what happened earlier this
summer the Russos were joking about Nova
being in Avengers in-game with someone
asked them during a big Q&A session this
is the clip of them talking about
Richard Reiter
being in Avengers endgame macho man
Russo brothers how do you guys not have
any Nova Corp member in a fight against
Thanos love the movie but just boggles
my mind didn't even have to be Richard
Ryder I look closely at that scene again
there and you will see there are
thousands of people yeah you will see
Richard Ryder in the background of a
shot Easter Egg everyone thank you so
much these were great questions yes yeah
sending in these questions we really
appreciate it and hopefully you got
satisfactory answers yeah and I
hopefully you have answers of your own
after they posted that clip the internet
went crazy everyone did their customary
zoom in and enhance all over the
Avengers end game final battle looking
for Richard Ryder Nova the Russos came
out a couple days later and clarified no
we were just joking around he didn't
actually make it into the final cut of
the film so don't bother looking in this
big final battle scene because you won't
actually find him but then a little
while later it was revealed that there
was a giant deleted Nova storyline and
there was a version of Avengers endgame
where he was in that final battle and he
goes all the way back to the beginning
of Avengers infinity war because it was
sort of the situation like you have with
Captain Marvel in the movie where they
show up at the beginning then they show
up at the end so the Nova deleted
storyline starts with an Avengers
infinity war prequel Thanos at the
beginning of infinity war has chosen to
quote/unquote do it himself and go after
the Infinity stones that timeline starts
during the Avengers age of Ultron
post-credit scene where he grabs the
gauntlet that's how far back this goes
but in the timeline that
happening right before Avengers infinity
war starts right after this scene of him
smiling into camera he goes straight to
Xandar attacks the Nova Corps to
take the Power Stone from them then uses
it to destroy the planet just like Ronan
almost did during the original guardians
of the galaxy movie it was a massive
massive battle scene that they
originally intended to open infinity war
an endgame with just to show you how
powerful Thanos was even without the
Infinity stones he was able to level the
Nova Corps before he took the Power
Stone visually it looked very similar to
Thanos from 2014 annihilating the New
Avengers base at the end of Avengers
endgame with just as normal ships in
weaponry before he tried to steal the
Infinity Gauntlet from them so Thanos
knows almost kills all the Nova Corps
including Nova prime but Richard Ryder
survives in this and Arion world mine
gives him his Nova powers so essentially
they're doing the Nova origin story from
the comics they're just using fan OHS in
the Infinity Gauntlet is the catalyst
for that because before this Richard
Ryder was just a normal space cop before
he gained total control over the Nova
Force they were really clear about what
the Nova Force would actually look like
during Avengers infinity war in Avengers
end game but it's a pool of energy that
all the members of the Nova Corps are
allowed to draw from the lights on the
symbols and their armor is just an
indicator for how much power they're
drawing for most low-level officers like
the people that are locking up the
guardians of the galaxy here is just
basic minor armor enhancements nothing
else but when the living computers of
the Xandarian world mind give Richard
Ryder total and so access to the power
source
it makes him one of the most powerful
Avengers level characters you can argue
in the comments about who would be more
powerful someone like Scarlet Witch who
got her powers from an infinity stone or
someone like Richard Reiter who draws
his powers from the Nova force I saw a
lot of theories when Avengers endgame
came out about Nova getting his powers
from an infinity stone - and them trying
to explain it that way is always
possible they could change that later on
but once Richard Ryder in the movie gets
his full Nova force powers their plan
was to use them in a very similar way to
what they did with Captain Marvel early
seen as part of that huge battle that
opened the movies then he goes away for
a long time during that five-year time
jump and comes back for the Avengers end
game final battle you get to see him
using some of his powers and that big
Paige seen in the background when
everyone's flying across the frame at
the same time and then they set up his
storyline for Marvel phase 4 Marvel
phase 5 in what they're going to do in the
Nova movie the basic plan for the Nova
movie at least right now and this could
always change down the road is that they
use flashbacks to explain what was
happening when he actually gets his
powers after Thanos' attack what he did
during the five year avengers endgame
time job and then establish all the
characters that they'll be using in his
movies the thing about the Nova Corps is
that Xandarian space borders Crete in
Skrull space so a lot of you have
probably already figured this out he's
right next to the sector of space the
Captain Marvel patrols so they share a
lot of space space villain characters
between the two of them between the
Skrulls and the Kree they're a ton of
super weird Nova villains that they can
use is the main villain of his movie and
obviously if it's successful they'll do
multiple Nova movies some of the biggest
ones that we have not seen in the MCU
yet are Annihilus remember when
everybody thought that they were going to
use anihilation conquest is the plotline
of avengers endgame in the annihilators
we're going to come that was actually a
pretty big early theory it sounds like
they're still going to use them eventually
but we won't see them until Marvel phase
5 or some future space based movie
because there are so many cosmic movies
that they're developing now aside from
guardians of the galaxy volume 3 there's
now the Nova movie there's the Captain
Marvel sequels and the Silver Surfer
movie that they're working on that
doesn't even get into the x-men
space-based movies like starjammers it
would actually be awesome to see them
show up in a guardians of the galaxy
movie but a lot of the other big Nova
villains like apox or just super
versions of Skrulls not the super skrull
just a skrull that is way more powerful
than normal Skrulls
that's why his movie will probably share
a lot in common with the guardians of
the galaxy movies but right now the
actual Nova movie wouldn't come out till
after Captain Marvel 2 in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 we know the Captain
Marvel 2 is going to take place on earth at
least a little bit because Kevin Feige
confirmed that they're doing it after
the Miss Marvel phase 4 series they
introduced Kamala Khan during that then
she crosses over into the movies in the
Captain Marvel sequel Feige said that
she's a character in present day
ergo part of Captain Marvel 2 has to
take place in present day after Avengers
end game right now guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 is probably going to come
out in 2022 sometime after a black
panther to black
anther two is May 20-22 that's the only
movie that they've confirmed for that
year but we know that they're going to do
guardians of the galaxy volume 3
they can totally introduce him
spider-man Captain America Civil War
style with a cameo in someone else's
movie like I said guardians of the
galaxy volume three is probably going to
make more sense just because they have
such weird characters in those movies
and most of Novas villains are pretty
weird but just based on all that we
might not wind up seeing the Nova
character till 2022 2023 unless they
want a shoehorn him into some earlier
movie there just aren't a lot of space
space movies outside of Thor for love
and thunder in the next two to three
years they don't really have any actors
that they're looking at right now so
you're free to fan cast any one you want
for Richard Wright or Nova but he'd be
around the same age as star-lord younger
character but not that young but a lot
of these big space base cosmic plans
that Marvel is making for phase four in
phase five make a lot more sense now
that we've seen that spider-man far from
home post-credit scene with Nick Fury
where he's on the sword Space Station
the whole reason why they took him into
outer space is because he's basically
going to be putting a new team of
Avengers together for Avengers 5 so as a
way to differentiate the new phase of
Avengers Avengers 5 they're taking those
movies into outer space with big cosmic
threats and all the Marvel phase 4
series that they just announced at Comic
Con at d23 will mostly take place on
earth so that's how they're sort of
dividing up territories in the Marvel
Universe we're going cosmic with the big
Avengers level stuff everything else is
going to be down on planet earth and if
you missed it during the spider-man far
from home post credits scene Talos sort
of let's slip there our crease sleeper
cells on planet earth what that implies
is is that there do Secret Invasion but
instead of the Skrulls doing Secret
Invasion like the comics it'll actually
be the creed that invade because the way
they've set them up so far is that the
Skrulls are good in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and it's the Kree that are bad
so we're still getting Secret Invasion
at some point but they might choose to
cover that in one of the solo movies
instead of doing it in an Avengers movie
but ever
many post all your Nova theories in the
comments below space cop flying around
do you want to see him pop-up and
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 or do you
think the he'll show up in somebody
else's movie there's more Marvel deleted
scenes in bonus videos I'm working on
the next couple of days but leave all
your requests in the comments below
congratulations zombie bro 9 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my new
spider-man sinister 6 video and click
here to learn about Tom Welling Superman
coming back for the big crisis on infinite earths
crossover this year
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!